because with the srs you can't do that
what's up
i
oh
foreign
thank you
the cables
uh
hasn't i've been here
um
okay
yes
is
i don't want to be the only person out
there
on yeah de blasio was all about it yeah
well i mean
so she left him like a couple of years
ago
i think
thank you
yes
uh
hey
i've been in the bureau mainly
um
okay
free camera
dude
yeah yeah
okay
um
um
um
we um not yet
um
oh
i'm um
um
um
um
recently i feel like
oh
maybe you can
um
uh
oh
um
anyways
yes
uh
that's good
um
briefing begins
here
this button
did you guys say
okay
confused
hi everyone happy friday
uh we are ending the week with a very
special guest
uh national security advisor jake
sullivan
um he's our first repeat guest here must
be a lot going on in this world
um he's going to give us a readout of
the quad meeting
that took place this morning and also of
course answer some of your questions
thanks jen good to see everybody today
so as jen said this morning the
president hosted the first ever quad
summit
uh the first time that this group
gathered at the leader's level of course
they gathered virtually because of the
constraints of covet 19. each of the
leaders
independently in the course of the
meeting referred to this event as
historic
because it cemented a group of strong
democracies that will
work together going forward to secure a
free and open indo-pacific
president noted in his opening remarks
that this is the first
multilateral summit he's hosted since
taking office
and that's on purpose it reflects his
view
that we have to rally democratic allies
and partners in common cause
and his belief in the centrality of the
indo-pacific to the national security of
the united states
during the meeting the leaders addressed
key regional issues including
excuse me including freedom of
navigation and freedom from coercion
in the south and east china seas the
dprk nuclear issue
and the coup and violent repression in
burma the president and his counterparts
also spoke to the competition of models
between autocracy and
democracy and express their confidence
that despite setbacks and imperfections
democracy
is the best system to deliver for people
and to meet the economic
social and technological challenges of
the 21st century and i have to say that
over the course of the meeting
a sense of optimism for the future
despite the hard times we're in was on
full display
the four leaders did discuss the
challenge posed by china
and they made clear that none of them
have any illusions about china but today
was not
fundamentally about china much of the
focus
was on pressing global crises including
the climate crisis
and covet 19. and with respect to
covid19 these four leaders made a
massive
joint commitment today with indian
manufacturing
u.s technology japanese and american
financing
and australian logistics capability the
quad committed to delivering
up to 1 billion doses to asean
the indo-pacific and beyond by the end
of 2022.
the leaders also agreed that they would
meet in person before the end of the
year
and they launched a set of working
groups including an emerging technology
group
that will help set standards in key
technologies like 5g and artificial
intelligence
and another on cyber that will help our
four countries
meet this growing threat these groups
will deliver results
by the time of the summit i just
referred to that will happen before the
end of the year
the quad at the end of the day at the
end of today is now a critical part of
the architecture of the indo-pacific
and today's summit also kicks off an
intensive stretch
of diplomacy in the region secretary
blinken and secretary austin will travel
to japan and korea to meet with their
counterparts
in a two plus two format they're getting
on the road this weekend
secretary austin will go on to india
from there
secretary blinken and i will
subsequently meet the senior chinese
officials in anchorage alaska and we
will have other high-level meetings and
visits in the coming weeks
with leaders from the indo-pacific that
will be announced soon
just a word on anchorage before i turn
to your questions
we've spoken a lot about our fundamental
strategy of establishing a position of
strength
in the early going and after the work of
the past 50 days
secretary blinken and i will enter the
meeting with senior chinese
representatives
from a position of strength president
biden has signed into law the american
rescue plan and the oecd has now
projected that our
economic growth will be the highest in
decades and will help power
global economic growth we're ahead of
schedule on the president's ambitious
goal of 100
million shots in 100 days we've launched
a bold effort to secure our critical
supply chains
we've reclaimed our place in key
international institutions
and with the current presidency of the
un security council
we passed a strong statement on burma
just this week
we've revitalized our alliances in asia
and europe
last week with the europeans we agreed
to a pause in tariffs in the
long-running
boeing airbus dispute and we executed a
strong joint response
to russia's poisoning of alexey navalny
we've begun deep consultations with our
european partners
on a common approach to our concerns
with china
in asia just in the last few days we've
reached new hosting agreements for our
troops
and our bases with both korea and japan
and now we've taken the quad to a new
level
so make no mistake today is a big day
for american diplomacy this summit is a
big deal for the president and for the
country and we are looking forward to
the work ahead and with that
i would be happy to take your questions
yeah uh thank you sir uh jennifer jacobs
from bloomberg news
in the quad meeting this morning did the
president and his counterparts discuss
the cyber attack
on the microsoft exchange and also i'm
also wondering if they discussed the um
the chips shortage the semiconductors
and was there any solution to that
without getting into too much detail
they discussed both recent cyber attacks
and semiconductors in the course of the
conversation today and indeed
the leaders agreed as part of the
emerging technology working group
to look at this supply chain question
including as it relates to
semiconductors to make sure that we
don't have shortages of critical
materials going forward
whether it's semiconductors or rare
earths and with respect to cyber
the impetus behind this new cyber
working group is not just
the solar winds incident or the
microsoft exchange incident both of
which the united states is responding to
with urgency but also cyber attacks that
have hit
japan india and australia just in the
past
past few weeks and months so this is a
common challenge that we face
from both state actors and non-state
actors and
we do intend to make the quad a central
vehicle for cooperation on cyber yeah
on this cyber attack of microsoft can
you give us a
the scope and scale of this how it might
compare to solar winds
and is this still ongoing uh it is still
ongoing in the sense that we are still
gathering information we are still
trying to determine
the scope and scale it is significant
but the precise number of systems
that have been exposed by this
vulnerability and have been exploited
either by nation state threat actors or
ransomware hackers or
others that is something that we are
urgently working with the private sector
to determine
uh it is certainly the case that uh
the malign actors are still in some of
these microsoft exchange systems which
is why we have pushed so hard
to get those systems patched to get
remediation underway
and the us government is mobilizing a
robust
whole of government response to it
ultimately a lot of this comes down to
the private sector taking the steps that
they need to take to remediate
and we will give them everything we can
to help them be able to do so
yeah can you declaratively say that the
microsoft exchange hack
was done by china i'm not in a position
standing here today to provide
attribution but i do pledge to you that
we will be in a position to attribute
that attack at some point in the near
future
and we won't hide the ball on that we
will come forward and say
who we believe perpetrated the attack
talk about diplomacy i want to ask you
about iran right now what is the status
of any talks with iran given they rebuff
the us's effort
to meet with them diplomacy with iran is
ongoing just not in a direct fashion at
the moment
there are communications through the
europeans
and through others that enable us to
explain to the iranians what our
position is with respect to
the compliance for compliance approach
and to hear what their position is
and we're waiting at this point to hear
further from the iranians how they would
like to proceed
but from our perspective this is going
to be
you know this is not going to be easy
but we believe that we are
in a diplomatic process now that we can
move forward on
and ultimately secure our objective
which is to prevent iran from getting a
nuclear weapon and to do so through
diplomacy
as it relates to iran is the u.s not
going to respond to the last round of
rocket attacks that hit al-assad and we
heard from the former secretary of state
mike pompeo on the last couple days
saying that ayatollah recognizes
only strength is the us demonstrating
weakness
in terms of that relationship so first
of all if you look at the pattern of
attacks that took place over the course
of 2019 and 2020
against american personnel and
facilities how frequently they
occurred uh what kind of damage they did
i'm not sure that the former secretary
is in a position to be trying to give us
advice on the question of how to respond
secondly the united states reserves the
right to protect its personnel and its
facilities we will do so at a time and
place of our choosing
and we will take whatever steps are
necessary to deter further attacks and
to impose costs on those who attack us
but i'm not going to telegraph our
punches on any particular operation that
we may take
in the days or weeks ahead yeah uh thank
you jake john fuller with
sarasota press um on a sort of broader
picture
as a candidate uh now president biden
called saudi arabia pariah
he vowed a new approach in china he got
to be tough on putin
um you know but as he's in his early
days administration both republicans
democrats alike have suggested
that he's taking a little more cautious
more conservative approach what should
we read into this is this him
is this him displaying a more realist
more realism approach to foreign policy
why not perhaps uh be the optimist that
he did on the campaign trip
joe biden is the ultimate optimist and
today was the ultimate testament to his
optimism
uh pulling together for the first time
ever the leaders of japan
australia and india in a grouping
that is going to allow the united states
to drive forward
its agenda its interests and its values
more effectively going forward
and to lift up democracy as
uh the signal form of government that
can deliver for people and meet the
challenges going ahead so
you heard him last night in his speech
about where we're going to be on covet
19. you heard him yesterday at the bill
signing about domestic renewal
and you heard him today about his deep
belief that the united states will be in
a position to lead
and to succeed in the 21st century on
the global stage
that that's the broad answer to your
question the more specific answer to
your question is that let's take each of
those in turn
on saudi arabia the president said he
was going to change
america's relationship with saudi arabia
and he has
he has not only removed
american support for offensive
operations in yemen
he has also taken additional steps to
sanction individuals
and to publish something the last
administration was not prepared to do
an unclassified report on the murder of
jamal khashoggi
he has also indicated to the saudis that
that going forward we are not going to
give them the blank check the last
administration did
either on how they treat their own
citizens or how they operate in the
region
but at the end of the day his metric is
what's going to advance american
interests and values
and our near-term interest right now is
to get a ceasefire
in the war in yemen so that we reduce
humanitarian suffering there
and to get de-escalation in the region
so that we
uh increase america's security and the
security of our allies and partners
on both of those issues he has pushed
saudi arabia hard and we believe that we
are making progress as a result of his
policy
if you look at russia and china he has
both taken
a firm line with respect to russia
including working with the europeans to
impose costs already
for the poisoning of alexey navalny and
preparing additional responses to other
malign actions that russia has conducted
and as far as china is concerned the
united states as he has said repeatedly
believes that we are going to end up in
a stiff competition with china and we
intend to prevail in that competition
and he is amassing the sources of
strength we need to be able to prevail
and that is a hundred percent in line
with everything that joe biden said on
the campaign trail
and 50 days in we believe we are in a
better position
to deal with the challenge from china
than we than we were the day that he
took office
news yeah thanks for coming in and
taking our questions i want to ask you a
question about
immigration diplomacy when he was vice
president joe biden went to guatemala
in the summer of 2014. you were on that
trip as his national security advisor at
the time he went because of
what was then an unprecedented surge of
unaccompanied minors coming across the
border
one of the things he said on that trip
in june of 2014 was we can
a first make clear in each of our
countries in an
unrelenting way not just for the public
service announcement
but there is no free pass that none of
these children
or women bringing children will be
eligible under the existing law in the
united states of america
he said that was number one and then he
went on to describe root causes and
american aid
why has that not been the message that
this white house is sending now
clear and unrelenting that none of these
children or women bringing children will
be eligible
under the existing law so the president
has
made clear and this administration has
made clear that we are going to pursue
an effective and humane immigration
policy and unwind
what we believe was the ineffective and
inhumane policy over the course of the
last four years
that's point number one point number two
is we've made clear that now
is not the time to come to the united
states we are dealing with a
circumstance
in which uh we have to build the
capacity to be able to assess the asylum
claims of individuals who arrive here
and we have to deal with the obvious
public health effects of a pandemic
so we are sending the message clearly
and you heard it from roberta jacobson
from this podium earlier this week we're
doing so in the region as well
but the president also believes that
under our laws
people who are claiming asylum deserve
to have their cases heard
properly effectively efficiently and as
swiftly as possible and that is the
policy that we are going to pursue
we really believe that message is being
received clearly in an unrelenting way i
mean there was a young man
quoted in the wall street journal this
week who said that this president seems
more
friendly to him than the prior one and
he believes he'll be able to come to the
united states on that basis
so this is day by day something that we
need to be able to uh
to communicate from a range of different
perspectives from this podium in the
region
itself on the airwaves and we will
continue to do so as we go forward
yeah just to follow to next week's
meeting with representatives from china
um
do you think that tariffs and export
controls targeting china will be part of
the talks
and what does china need to do for the
us to dial
back on tariffs and explore
i don't expect that uh for example the
phase one trade deal is going to be a
major topic of conversation next week
this is
our effort to communicate clearly to the
chinese government
how the united states intends to proceed
at a strategic level
what we believe our fundamental
interests and values are and what our
concerns
with their activities are whether it's
on hong kong or xinjiang or in the
taiwan strait
or frankly the issues that we heard
today from our quad partners their
coercion of australia
their harassment around the senkaku
islands uh
their aggression on the border with
india so this will stay more in that
zone than get into the details
uh of questions around tariffs or export
controls but we will communicate
that the united states is going to take
steps
in terms of what we do on technology to
ensure that our technology is not being
used
in ways that are inimical to our values
or
adverse to our security we will
communicate that message at a broad
level but in terms of the details of
these issues
we have more work to do with our allies
and partners to come up with a common
approach
a joint approach before we go sit down
point by point
with the chinese government on these
issues we will also want to bring other
key representatives
senior economic representatives of the
biden administration into those
conversations at the point in time when
they're appropriate to occur
um taiwan's um foreign minister has said
uh he wants to see more
security cooperation with the quad um do
you see
the coordinate coordination between the
different nations as a way of perhaps in
increasing the potential cost to china
of any move against taiwan
and did taiwan and its state has come up
in your discussions this morning
uh so the way that we look at this is
that the quad is not a military alliance
it's not a new nato despite
some of the propaganda that's out there
what it is is an opportunity for these
four democracies to work as a group
and also with other countries on
fundamental issues
of economics technology climate and
security
so i'm not going to get into detail on
what the elements of that security will
look like because we have work to do
as an emergent institution to define
what the agenda looks like what we know
is that broad-based maritime security
is already core to the quad agenda that
humanitarian assistance and disaster
response
and the work of our militaries in that
space is already on the agenda
where we go from there on everything
from freedom of navigation to broader
regional security questions
that has to be worked through uh not
just at the leaders level but at the
working level as well so
we'll see how that unfolds over the
course of the months to come
please jake oh sure thank you uh we're
reporting
reuters for reuters thank you uh that uh
we're reporting that india is likely to
block its mobile carriers from carrying
or using telecoms equipment by huawei
is that something that the united states
welcomes
the united states has expressed its
concerns about huawei
and uh the relationship between huawei
and elements of the chinese government
and military apparatus
and so this is a sovereign decision for
india to make but
we certainly think it's consistent with
the decisions that we've made and
advocated as well
upon the vaccines we have we also have
reporting from india that
the temporary us ban on exports of key
raw materials for vaccines
could affect the objective of quickly
ramping up production
is the us open to easing that ban so
uh first the president had the
opportunity to speak with the prime
minister about this bold initiative that
we're undertaking
and we feel very good about our ability
to execute against that
secondly i do not believe that there is
an export ban
but the united states will happily work
with countries around the world
to make sure that we are doing our part
not just to make sure every last
american citizen is vaccinated as
quickly as possible but that the rest of
the world gets vaccinated as quickly as
possible as well so i'll leave it at
that thanks guys
okay just have a couple of items at the
top um
in all of the news and then in the
speech last night i just wanted to just
give a brief overview of
some of the announcements the president
made about how we were going to
uh that give more detail i should say on
how we're going to
meet his commitment of uh of course
directing states to ensure that every el
every american is eligible to receive
the vaccine by may first
how we're going to expedite it and how
we're going to get to the point where we
are having july 4th barbecues uh so
first
he announced
to up to 700 additional community health
centers
that reach underserved communities
bringing the total number
of community health centers
participating in our federal vaccination
program
to 950 and this is hugely important as
we're talking about addressing
access vaccine hesitancy meeting people
where they are in communities because
these health centers are
trusted places in many communities where
people go and they get
regular health services and so this will
dramatically increase that
he is going to we're going to double the
number of pharmacies participating in
the federal pharmacy program
when we first announced this if you all
remember we announced that it was a
pilot program we're going to see how it
went it's extremely successful
and it has been very effective around
the country and so now the
vaccine will be available at more than
20 000 pharmacies across
the country uh he will also more than
double the number of federally run
mass vaccination centers to ensure that
we reach the hardest hit communities and
he talked about this
in the speech and we've seen these in
communities across the country and many
of you have covered this where you can
drive up in your car with your family
members get the vaccine
and it is quite inefficient and they can
reach often thousands of people in these
vaccination sites and also announced the
deployment of more than four thousand
active duty troops to support
vaccination efforts bringing the total
to over six thousand all so that's
obviously a significant increase
and expanded vaccinators the people who
can give these vaccines
to dentist optometrist paramedics
physician assistants veterinarians
and many more uh so the last piece and i
announced much of this yesterday and i
think you're all quite familiar with
what he's doing next week but
in the in the uh for tradition here uh
next week the president vice president
first lady and the second gentleman will
hit the road to talk to the american
people
about the benefits of the american
rescue plan on monday
he will host an event at the white house
on the implementation of the american
rescue plan
on tuesday he will travel to delaware
county pennsylvania as part of the help
is here tour
to amplify the american rescue plan and
on friday the president and the vice
president
will travel to georgia to continue
engaging with americans about how they
will benefit
from the rescue plan jonathan go ahead
um
a number of influential new york
lawmakers including representatives
nadler and ocasio-cortez have now called
the resignation of governor palmer
in the light of new allegations of
harassment including one that was
referred
to law enforcement my first question is
simply this does the president believe
the governor should resign
the president uh believes that every
woman who's come forward there have now
been
six i believe who have come forward
deserves to have her voice heard should
be treated with respect
uh and should be able to tell her story
there also is an independent
investigation that is ongoing of course
in the state
with subpoena power overseen by the
attorney general and he certainly
supports
that moving forward uh we of course have
watched the news of a number of
lawmakers call for that
uh but i don't have any additional
announcements from here
on this in light of the investigation in
light that he has had some of his
pandemic response powers taken away does
the white house still have faith in
governor cuomo if he remains his
position
overseeing the response to the pandemic
in the state of new york
well we certainly don't want anyone in
the state of new york to be penalized
um meaning uh not have access to
vaccines to vaccinators not have access
to
uh funding from the rescue plan and
certainly we will continue to work with
a range of officials to
get that done and get it implemented but
the president and our coveted response
team works with
governors across the country uh
including governor cuomo uh
to implement these plans and we'll
continue to do that okay
one other topic go ahead um there are
more than 10 million doses of the
astrazeneca vaccine in the u.s
that can't be administered here but
could save lives in europe and
other places in the world if the company
was freed from the obligation to deliver
those doses to the us government
the company has appealed the
administration to let them export
those doses why is the president not
agree well let me just take a step back
here and explain
kind of what's going on here uh first as
we state a few times but we're through
stating
the president's priority and focus is on
ensuring that
uh the the american people are
vaccinated obviously he made
some significant announcements last
night about the timeline of that and we
will have enough doses
uh in our hands by the end of may to
ensure we can make that happen
astrazeneca is also not yet approved by
the fda we also want to make sure we
have
maximal flexibility that we are
oversupplied and over prepared
and that we have the ability to provide
vaccines whatever the most effective
ones are
to the american public there are still
1400 people who are dying in our country
every single day
and we need to focus on addressing that
um
at this time there have been requests
around the world of course from a number
of countries who
have requested doses from the united
states and we have not provided
doses from the us government to anyone
so this is not about
europe this is about uh our focus and
our priority which we have been very
public
and clearly stated and what you're
referencing in terms of
access to doses of course the um
production part of the production is
through the defense
is is enabled because of the defense
production act
there is a contract obligation to
deliver on
the u.s doses and to fulfill that
contract
but any company astrazeneca is not a u.s
company
they can also work with and even if they
were they can work with any country
to fulfill and to work on a deal to get
access to doses
we just heard from jake sullivan talking
about on immigration the need to have a
consistent and continued message to
communicate to migrants that the border
is closed right now we saw ambassador
jacobson he says there has to be
a message on the airwaves and in that
region as well if you want to send the
message to migrants that the border is
closed
shouldn't president biden be the one who
is clearly delivering that message
well he he did do an interview with
univision about two weeks ago and
and made that absolutely clear and i i
certainly expect he will
uh look for the opportunity to do
exactly that i will note however that
um he is one of the voices ambassador
jacobson is one of the voices
there are a number of effective voices
in the region including
leaders in the region including uh voice
partners we need to have in the region
ngos and others to deliver the same
message that now is not the time to come
that the majority of people are turned
away at the border which is
backed up by factual data that
adults families will be turned away at
the border in
almost every scenario and so that is
part of the data and part of the
information that we're looking for
partnership to deliver in the region
is it working well again peter i think
we we know we've seen the numbers that
cbp puts out
on a regular basis we know there are
more children uh children under the age
of 18 who are of course coming
across the border we that is consistent
with what our policy has been
uh but in terms of people who were
turned away um
who are coming to the border who are
turned away i mean those numbers or are
people hearing that are they still
making the journey i don't
have any further analysis of that i know
that what people are looking at
is that there are more children who are
coming across the border and we've
certainly confirmed and acknowledged
that let me ask you about the
president's
speech last night this was a speech
about the anniversary the last year
since the pandemic began of course you
spent a lot of time
touting the success of vaccines yet
there was no mention of the president
under whose administration these
vaccines
were developed does former president
trump not deserve
any credit on vaccines well the
president himself
and and many people in our
administration have conveyed that
having making the progress that was made
and we've said this publicly
that was made on these vaccines was a
herculean incredible effort
by science and by medical experts and
certainly we have applauded that in the
past and we're happy to applaud that
again but i would say there is a clear
difference
and there are clear steps that have been
taken since the president took
office uh that have put us in a
trajectory that we were not on
when he was inaugurated and leadership
starts at the top
it includes mask wearing it includes
acknowledging there's a pandemic it
includes getting a vaccine in public
but even more importantly than that it
includes putting in place an
operational process that it that it can
ensure that we have enough vaccines to
vaccinate americans enough vaccinators
enough vaccine locations none of that
was in place
when the president took office certainly
that's on distribution and elect but on
the development of the vaccines it was
operation warp speed that was invented
executed initiated under the former
president so in the spirit of
bipartisanship and unity last night
as opposed to the first comments which
spoke about the denials in the first
days weeks and months
why don't you say with credit to the
previous administration and the former
president for putting us in this
position we are glad that we have been
able to move it forward
that is an excellent recommendation as a
speech writer but
we had the president has spoken to it in
the past he has
applauded the work of medical experts
and scientists and
the prior administration and what the
purpose of last night's speech was was
to give an update on what his
administration has been doing what he
has done since took
he took office the progress that's been
made what the work is ahead
provide a light at the end of the tunnel
and ask americans to engage in the
process so
and and do what's needed to be done so
we can get to those july 4th barbecues
as he said to bring all americans
together which is why i asked of course
that is but you know i would say that
americans are looking for facts they're
looking for details they're looking for
specifics
uh and i don't think they're worried too
much about uh applause from
six months ago when the president has
already delivered that publicly
go ahead you just said that leadership
starts at the top when it comes to
getting colbid vaccines out but when you
describe the messaging on immigration
you're talking about leadership from
ambassador jacobson and many others
getting the word and i don't think
that's what i said but
well you were explaining why president
biden is not out here
i i actually well to be to be factual
because we're all about facts
i actually started by saying he did an
interview with univision just two weeks
ago and that he would look for
opportunities to
continue to deliver that message clearly
himself but that there are a number of
voices that
are important and effective and can be
heard in the region and that
we will certainly use a number of voices
to communicate directly in the region
so we've heard from uh some folks down
at the border
in brownsville texas specifically of
migrants
who are being tested by some of the ngos
down there for kobut
they test 1700 at least 204 positive
tests so far that's over a nine percent
positivity rate more than double the
national average
so what is the federal government doing
to perfect
to protect the citizens of a town like
brownsville texas
well i don't know whether i'm i'm not
questioning the data but i certainly
would refer to cbp and i'm happy to get
more specific data officially from cbp
data on the testing well let me walk you
through
because obviously there are a number of
categories of individuals who are coming
and this is a question you've asked
before and certainly an understandable
question
so individuals who are taken into and so
i'm just going to give you an outline of
the testing
into ice cast custody uh migrants and
entering ice facilities are tested upon
intake
and they're quarantined if they test
positive that's one category of course
unaccompanied children of course another
category all unaccompanied children
encountered at the border receive a
medical screening
by contract medical professionals that
includes a medical assessment or health
intake interview
minor issues are treated on site and
major issues are referred to a local
hospital so when a
child is released into our custody they
quarantine for 10 to 14 days
and receive covet testing through hhs uh
those who are uh you know come into the
country and are
treated with alternatives to detention
sometimes that's ankle bracelets and
other means of tracking
dhs works with city and county leaders
as well as public health officials to
provide
coven 19 testing and is needed isolation
and quarantine
for families released from border patrol
facilities and that's something we've
talked about a bit in here
in terms of a proposal that was made by
dhs
and fema in coordination with ngos and
local authorities to
fully cover and pay for the testing that
up to this point the governor has
declined that uh proposal
but based on what you've said before in
our understanding of the policy it's
just
guidance that these migrants who test
positive many of them
are instructed you should go and
quarantine and isolate
do you know does the administration know
how many actually do
versus how many actually just go off to
wherever
well i just wanted to convey because i
know you're asking a good question here
that's
the very specific processes that are
taken for each scenario
um and certainly there are um you know
with these with the individuals who are
coming across alternatives
who are treated with again noted
sometimes ankle bracelets as they come
across while they're waiting for
um adjudication of their cases um those
are
the steps that are taken those are the
recommendations that are made and i just
noted that
testing is a propos there's a proposal
for testing all of these individuals as
they
come across um so that's what our policy
processes are but
in terms of specific data and numbers i
would certainly refer you to cbp or i'm
happy to talk to them as well and you
know
if there are any administration
discussions about vaccinating some of
these migrants who are
being held for much longer than normal
or much longer than in previous
administrations to stop the spread
in the shelters uh that's a really good
question i would say
obviously we're focused on vaccinating
uh
you know eligible uh americans in the
country but we
um do believe that elig vaccinating as
many people as possible keeps all of us
safe and keeps all of us and ensures the
safety of all people living here
um but i'm not aware of any plans we are
very focused on
addressing and taking steps to address
the public health
uh challenges uh that we're seeing uh up
in the bor across the border of course
with the pure number of people the
number of people who are in cbp
facilities
and in these shelters we've talked a bit
about uh working with the cdc on
guidelines
but certainly with the pure numbers we
need to continue to look at and evaluate
ways to
uh prevent this from becoming more of a
public health challenge and then one
other topic quickly last night in speech
president biden reiterated his goalie
once a majority of school is open by his
100th day in office that's april 30th
yep one day later may 1st he says that
every adult is going to be eligible for
the vaccine
we know that teachers have been
prioritized
everywhere so why just the majority of
schools
as the goal instead of a specific high
percentage or say all schools well first
let me encourage you you could even go
cover it i bet the secretary of
education is having a
forum on schools and school reopening on
the 24th i believe it's the 24th
of march uh there are a lot of steps
that are are being taken
already by the department of education
they're issuing
a a um guide book a of best practices um
they're already engaging with schools
and school districts they're requiring
that any fun
school that is going to have access to
funding from the american rescue plan
produces a plan within 30 days to reopen
their school
the school district does i should say so
there are a number of steps underway
uh we of course want to have schools
reopen and have them reopen in
five days a week that's our objective
but it's in the excellent hands of the
secretary of education who is
this is his number one priority every
day as the president talked about in his
speech
last one would the white house be okay
or could the white house get behind a
proposal
for schools to remain in session
full-time through the summer
well some school districts will decide
to do that and they can use
funding from the american rescue plan to
do that or to help ensure they can do
that
so it's really going to be a decision
made district school district school
district and if that determination is
made
we certainly support that but that's
part of what secretary cardona will be
working out with school districts
go ahead thanks jen uh on the fourth of
july barbecues that you keep mentioning
yes
obviously a symbolic gold but how did
you arrive at that date
why the fourth of july is that the date
by which you believe
most adult americans will be able to be
vaccinated
well we'll have enough supply by the end
of may right and it will be state to
state
so we did not want to give a conclusion
of when
everybody will be fully vaccinated
because it really depends on a couple of
factors some which are out of our
control
right uh people who have concerns about
the safety and efficacy of vaccines
we need to continue to redouble our
efforts to address that
obviously some states will have faster
timelines than other states but
you know we recognize that with a may
first timeline of everyone being
eligible
with the ability to have uh vaccines for
every american
uh available or we'll have the supply
for them by may 31st that
we felt it would be a time on our health
and medical experts it would be a
timeline by which we could have
and again this is not large gatherings
as you know mary it is
uh having you know a small group of
friends and neighbors in your backyard
so it's certainly not a full return
to concerts and soccer stadiums but it
is a baby step toward that and our team
felt
confident that we could get to that
point so is it safe to say that by july
4th you think we're in the ballpark
where you could have most adult
americans vaccinated well i i
again many of the factors are out of our
control including
individuals being willing to take the
vaccine and that's why it was so
important for
uh the president to convey that um it is
safe
it is effective uh tell your friends and
neighbors it's safe and effective and
that will be a factor here and it is
going to require americans continuing to
wear masks continuing to social distance
getting the vaccine so that is a um a
light at the end of the tunnel but there
are a lot of steps that need to be taken
to get there
as the president mentioned last night
you're also launching new tools and
making
it easier to sign up including a website
yep why wait until may to roll that out
well there's already a pilot program
that is available in about half a dozen
states and we've talked about expanding
and building upon that
a lot of states also have um their own
uh their own websites where people can
go and of course pharmacies as you know
in a program we've massively expanded
as part of the announcement last night
you can do scheduling through there
this is a website that will make it
possible for americans to go see where
there is supply available
and we just wanted to make sure uh that
it was uh we had the time to have that
up and ready but
uh we we are confident we can do that by
that timeline
go ahead up thanks jen uh back to
astrazeneca
can you say how big is that stockpile
and then secondly on that on also on
astrazeneca when does the administration
expect them to seek the emergency youth
authorization that the eua sure both
excellent questions um i don't have any
a prediction for when they will seek it
you probably should have to ask them
that question and i don't have a
update on the amount of supply obviously
there was an order placed
last year prior to president biden
taking office
uh and as would not come as a surprise
to you given this is how it's worked
with every other
uh vaccine it doesn't mean you have all
of that right you often don't have much
of it
until uh there's approval and obviously
we're not gonna get ahead of the
approval
would you be able to follow up with that
with us and just let us know how many
doses are in that store
i'm not sure i we will have a number to
provide but i'm happy to check uh for
you on that
um go ahead uh jen one question on last
night
the president said he's directing states
to
ensure that all adults are eligible for
the vaccine by may 1.
what what more do states need to do
to achieve that goal because it sounded
a little bit like
he was putting the onus on states but
states are asking for more supply
right and they won't be able to do that
without more supply well
we wouldn't have done it if we didn't
anticipate that we
would have much more supply available
and that's certainly part of the process
and we are
providing that through state allocation
uh but also
directly to pharmacies and so it's
certainly as in each state as you know
jeff but there is different
prioritization of who is in each
order and so it's just conveying uh what
that should look like and hhs has the
authority to direct states to
uh to adjust their prioritization they
made that clear yesterday too about the
authority i guess i'm just wondering why
does he need to tell states this
is is is there a lag where states not
moving in that direction i think it was
uh
making clear that this was his
expectation of its
being a leader of governors and leaders
in the country of when
and providing some clarity to the
american public about
when they can expect to um be eligible
now some states will move faster than
others and we certainly anticipate that
uh some states that may have smaller
populations or bigger
you know bigger supplies as a result um
relatively so i should say they may be
faster and that certainly
we encouraged he wanted to provide
uh certainty and a timeline for the
american people uh so that they can
expect
uh when they can be eligible and you
know for months he's leveled with the
american people he tried to do that last
night and many of you have asked for a
timeline for eligibility uh
a timeline for vaccine supply and a
timeline for back to normal and
he was venturing to do that last night
okay and one
follow-up on astrazeneca you've made
very clear and the president has made
very clear that the
goal and priority is americans
do you does he see any moral dilemma
in sitting on some vaccine we don't know
the exact amount
that has been approved elsewhere that
could be saving other
people's lives in other countries while
the process
drags on for however long it will in the
united states
well we don't know and we don't can't
anticipate as you know
when the process will conclude but i
think his view is that his obligation
first obligation is to uh addressing
what is still a crisis in our country
right and what is still a circumstance
where uh you know yes he outlined last
night that there's a light at the end of
the tunnel but 1400 americans are dying
every single day
and he wants to have as the leader of
this country maximum flexibility now
as jake just outlined he also wants to
be
a key member of the global community and
send the message that
we are um want to be collaborative and
cooperative
and work with other countries to get the
global pandemic under control
no doubt that is a tricky balance but in
the middle of a pandemic we're still at
war with the pandemic
it is uh it was a priority to him to
ensure that he has maximum uh
flexibility uh as the
leader of this country good i'm just a
follow-up clarification on the
prioritization um
so last week or earlier this month the
white house called on states to
prioritize nature
vaccinations now the white house is
saying the state should open up
eligibility to everyone
as soon as possible so what i mean first
yeah so
so what does that mean right now for
advising states and
priority groups should they be getting
rid of them should they keep them in tax
i mean should they still be focusing on
teachers right now and how do they
how do they square all this stuff given
you know that they're saying that they
have shortages of vaccines right now
well
i think not that there are some who are
saying that and some who are not and
obviously we've been increasing
supply on nearly every single week
actually every single week we probably
have been increasing supply and as
you all know we will also have more and
more doses we have we'll have access to
as
the federal government to ensure that
states are getting an increase in supply
it's it's going to be decisions made
state by state on how they provide
clarity to the people in their state
i believe alaska is a state that has
already moved to eligibility for
everyone
so there are probably models that some
states can look to
teachers remain prioritized and that is
done primarily through the pharmacy
program it's been quite successful i
don't
i have not been heard reports of
confusion uh
in recent days at all about that program
and the implementation of it but
each state will have to decide how they
implement in their timeline and
he's just giving them the time to um be
able to implement
it in advance of may 1st glad
the president of pains last night in
speech to condemn attacks on asian
americans
called un-american and wrong they must
stop does the president
believe that his predecessor had
anything to do with the rise in attacks
on asian americans
i think um the president has spoken
about the concerns he had about the
rhetoric
and the um uh provoking of hate speech
by his predecessor um and i think he's
not made a secret about that
um but we're looking at this moment 50
days into an administration where
there are still many in the asian
american community
still live with fear uh still uh are
being threatened
still are being attacked and um he felt
it was important uh for him
as the president of the united states
and leader of this country to make clear
that that's
not acceptable and to condemn that
during his first primetime address and
so
that was more not a reflection of his
thinking about his predecessor more
about
looking at um what people are still
facing in this moment is there anything
more the administration can do
on this point there's a push on the hill
i understand to
have a doj official take on this problem
is that something that the president
would support and if absent legislation
is there something he could do or order
the attorney general
uh you know i think he would expect the
attorney general would make decisions
independently about how to best address
um but uh and i i'm happy to
talk with our policy team and see if
there's more obviously he signed the
executive order
in the early days and condemned these
actions last night and certainly
uh would expect as i said the department
of justice to make independent decisions
but i can see if there's any more
specific policy actions we can take
quick question about next week this is
the first irish president in some time
any plans for st patrick's day even here
at the white house
i expect we will have more to preview we
of course will be
recognizing st patrick's day um so
but i will have more to preview for you
on uh what that looks like um
probably later in the weekend or early
next week as it's being finalized go
ahead
yeah following up on the earlier
questions about july 4th
in order to reach that goal i mean is
there a certain percentage
of americans that need to be vaccinated
or if there's no number um you know what
does the situation need to look like do
we need to
continue on the pace that the country
has been on uh in recent weeks
well i think it's important to note that
this is we're not talking about a july
4th celebration on the mall
we're not quite there yet right or we're
not talking about
soccer stadiums being filled in
communities across the country that
might require
something more like what you're talking
about we're talking about
the american people being motivated
and excited by the fact that that if
they get vaccinated if they abide by
that there is going to be access there
will be access to vaccines
they will be eligible and if they take
steps to get vaccinated
uh to continue to wear mass to continue
to observe social distancing then
looking ahead to july 4th is an
aspirational moment
where people can plant small
get-togethers in their backyard but
we're not talking about a mass event
here where we're
or or return to total normalcy that's
not what this is this is a
step more toward um the kind of
socialization and engagement with
friends and family that
uh he knows as a human being people have
been missing over the last year yeah
another question
350 billion dollars in direct data yeah
and local governments uh you know state
local governments right now are going
through their budgeting processes
when might they be you know as the white
house been able to determine when
they'll be able to start getting
money from that aid it will be in one
large
chunk for municipalities and states or
will be over a staggered time what what
have you been able to
determine through the treasury
department yeah that's a great question
um i know treasury is working hard at um
ensuring that this money is getting out
the door that the
portions of the money they're overseeing
uh but i'd have to talk to them more
about how that will be implemented or
pushed out specifically
um and kind of what the timeline for
that will be and hopefully we'll have
more of an update on that early next
week but i'll see if anything is ready
before then yeah
final question uh under the american
rescue plan uh
in the 1400 checks that americans
receive
they're currently no protections to
prevent debt collectors from seizing
uh stimulus checks during the last year
the second round of stimulus checks
had such protections uh senator ron
wyden of oregon has a standalone bill
that would provide those productions
does the president believe elect
debt collectors should have access or
should not have access to that money and
does he support
the widen bill i haven't talked to our
legislative team about that
i know there were a number of
adjustments made post the implementation
of the
package in december to adjust and
address
issues like non-filers having access
ensuring um you know that we were
reaching people who
um weren't reached and were eligible so
i i would have to talk to treasury about
whether they have a concern about this
at this point in time or whether
protections have been put in place one
more i
forgot about the the 4 000 military uh
personnel
that the federal government plans on
extending
uh for the acceleration of vaccines has
it been determined where they are going
is it to help at vaccination centers
mega sites can you talk more about the
deployment of those
soldiers uh they typically help in all
sorts of locations where help is needed
and determined in coordination with
local
uh governors and local elected officials
and folks who are overseeing these
centers so it's really case by case and
state by state
um but i don't have a breakdown of where
they'll be going quite yet
um last night the the president again
said more americans have died from code
19 and died in world war 1 world two
vietnam war and now 9 11. the numbers
don't bear that out so
why is he said that again for a second
time well
i think it's i'll have to check on that
specifically for you
i don't have the numbers all in front of
me either but if it's important to you i
will follow up with you after the
briefing on it we've been called out for
once before so as a surprise we know you
did a line by line edit so it's a
surprise that it went in again
well i'm glad you're focused on the
important business but i'm happy to
check on it for you
um go ahead in the back eric phillips
with cbn news thanks for taking my
questions
wanted to know first of all considering
the challenges at the southern border
right now
what specifically can faith-based
organizations do to help
meet that challenge that's a great
question i mean faith-based
organizations are
um an incredibly important part of the
ngo community as you know as it relates
to addressing immigration in a humane
way and oftentimes helping to find
helping to connect these unaccompanied
children with
safe and vetted homes or sponsor homes
that's a key role that they play
uh they also play a key role in uh you
know working with local communities on
addressing needs that come up ngos
broadly but many of them are faith-based
uh as well so you know i think we see
faith-based organizations as an
important partner and addressing
um in addressing the um the
uh the challenges we're facing at the
border and ensuring that these
kids who are coming across are treated
humanely our treat
are uh or find uh safe safe
shelters and safe locations to be while
their cases are being adjudicated and
they play uh vital roles at every most
steps in the process
when it comes to the vaccine the
administration is saying hey
get vaccinated as soon as you can put
the vaccine that's available to you
first
yeah but what do you say to a
significant segment of the population
that has a moral problem with the
johnson johnson vaccine
because the company uses cells from
aborted fetal tissue
and its manufacturing process well i
know
that uh the vatican has conveyed that
all three vaccines are safe and
effective and i know that is a powerful
authority
for many uh who are close to their faith
but that is something that has also been
conveyed by health and medical experts
and
you know what so we have to recognize
that um
well that is sexual and i certainly
point you to uh those at those important
authorities
uh we are not always the best messengers
that hear
a democratic administration to
communicate to everyone in the public
about
the safety the efficacy and the
importance of taking the vaccine and so
we are very open to looking to working
with a range of partners and messengers
outside groups outside organizations and
conveying exactly that because we
believe that
ensuring the public is vaccinated saving
lives
is something that transcends political
party it transcends
um you know disagreements about a range
of of issues and so
we are very open to that and recognize
that we are not always the
going to be the right voice or the right
face for that message lastly i just want
to ask you
how is temporarily tightening war power
restrictions the places like
somalia yemen and libya going to be
beneficial to the us whereas
ambassadors in those places used to be
able to give the go ahead
now the white house has to at least for
now give the green light before these
actions can be taken sure well it was
important to the president and our
national security team that we take a
moment
to review the use of these powers uh
authorities
over the last several years uh it's not
forever
but uh they wanted to take a moment to
do that review at the beginning of an
administration and
make a determination about how to best
approach it moving forward um so that's
what it's a reflection of
okay go ahead thank you one of the
presidents and
one on gun control sure so a latest
police in-house at yahoo saw that 44
of unvaccinated republicans so they
would never get vaccinated
this is higher that we found than any
other group or crosstalk
are you worried that the vaccine
hesitancy from these republicans or
white republicans
will make it harder for president biden
it's goal of vaccinating all adults by
summer
and what is your guys's uh thought
or um what is the administration doing
to persuade republicans in particular to
get vaccinated you're
who are the affected messengers here
well um
we are concerned about vaccine hesitancy
in many communities across the country
um
because uh we are going to get to the
point clearly where we have
enough supply for uh to vaccinate every
american
very every adult in this country uh and
it will get to the point where we have
more vaccines than people who want to
take the vaccine and we
we see that on the horizon uh so
we have taken a number of steps in in
communities where we feel we can be
very effective messengers in uh and that
includes you know just a statistically
just because i know you were giving a
statistic about
um kind of white uh conservative
republicans but
uh black and brown communities are
actually the hardest hit by the pandemic
two times more death
and deaths and hospitalizations also
communities where there's high levels of
vaccine hesitancy and we have
taken a number of steps to uh to open as
i mentioned these community health
centers invest in more
mobile units a big issue though is
access and accessibility
and meeting people where they are
regardless of their political
affiliation
and so one of the steps we've taken and
we can effectively do
outside of any partisan politics is
ensure that there are
locations with trusted interested
locations community health centers
pharmacies where anybody of any
political persuasion can get the vaccine
and they don't need to wear
a joe biden sticker in order to do that
but we also recognize as i noted to in
response to the earlier question that
we are not always going to be the most
effective messenger
and there are outside organizations that
are doing a range of outreach uh doing
ads and things along those lines some
one that featured
uh former republican president bush and
others and i think that kind of work is
something we fully
support and we feel is important in
order to uh
increase the number of people who feel
comfortable and confident in the
effectiveness of the vaccine
follow up on that you have we've heard a
lot from the administration on very
specific plans about besides black and
brown communities and how they're being
disproportionately affected but is the
white house
thinking of how to reach republicans who
will not take the vaccine
talk about the ad um for president
bush's and then of course how to play
for president trump was not there is
there outreach to trump or to any other
high-profile republicans to talk to
these republicans so they will never
take the vaccine
i guess what i'm trying to say um but
maybe not clearly enough is that
we recognize as a democratic
administration uh with a democratic
president
that we may not be the most effective
messenger to communicate with uh
hardcore supporters of the former
president
and we have to be clear-eyed about that
now we also know
that it is not always famous people who
are the most effective messengers
and so when i was talking about access
what i was getting at
is that doctors medical experts
community leaders
are often not seen as faith leaders as
partisan officials
and so we also worked power to provide
funding
to work with these different
organizations to get into communities
and convey this is safe it's effective
it will save lives this is not a
partisan issue so
that is a step we are taking but yes
there are in terms of
elevating outside voices um we certainly
support that
uh but there are a lot there's a lot of
outside work that's happening on
on uh to reach out to these groups as
well we expect to see you know
any collaboration in the white house and
like high profile republicans you know
on twitter on instagram anything like
that to speak to these music just as
there are with other black and brown
people let me try this again so i mean i
i'm hearing you i just want to get very
specific about the
outreach to black and white communities
is very specific
so what i'm conveying is we are focused
on how do we address
the root issues and the the way the
approach that will solve the challenge
here
and and what i'm trying to get at is
that accessibility
it may not satisfy this conservative
republican and this
famous democrat working together that
may happen
right but i'm what the way that we have
seen through data
the way that our health and medical
experts have conveyed to us
is that uh making it accessible doing
that through community health centers
ensuring there is access and supply uh
making sure that uh local doctors
faith leaders leaders community leaders
have access to that have the information
is incredibly effective that's what
we're investing in and and can also be
quite effective with many of the groups
that you've talked about
okay one question i'm going to control
sure grenade to um
democratic supported bills about gun
control pass through the house now it
moves the senate
curious what the white house's outreach
is going to be to senate senators to try
to get 60
votes for um these two kind of very
important christopher progressive
legislation on gun control yeah well
first gun safety measures and putting in
place
background checks is something the
president has been personally committed
to
for many years of his career he thinks
it is
long overdue uh it is steps that will
help
save lives keep community safe children
safe school safe
and he has fought against the nra many
times and and won
a few of those times as well so um he
will of course be talking with
um leaders uh and uh members of congress
about
how to move forward with gun safety
measures uh it's a priority to him but i
don't have any specific outreach to read
out to you go ahead
uh thanks i have another question about
state aid under the american rescue plan
we're coming up on a month out from the
texas
blackouts snowstorm can texas
use this state aid under under this
rescue plan
to weatherize its grid uh something that
the
the speaker of the texas house wants to
do he says well
the federal help was intended for
recovery from a disaster
and this is a disaster todd i'll have to
check on the technicality of that
and i can do it in the same way when i'm
following up on the questions i will go
back to the treasury department on i'm
not sure if there are
limitations in the use of it obviously
it's uh
intended broadly to ensure we're keeping
cops firefighters others on the beat but
i am happy to check and see if there's
flexibility in there
you want those cops to be cold all right
um
follow up yesterday you said 64
000 dhs workers
have gotten vaccinated um this was part
of the spat with governor
abbott yeah governor haven't said today
that there's a mass vaccination clinic
next week for border patrol agents
in the rio grande valley and he's saying
that that is coming in response to the
pressure that he's put on the
administration
um how many frontline workers have not
gotten shots
and was this a response how many border
patrol agents have not received shots
you'd have to ask them that specific
question what i was conveying is that
it's a priority we've made a priority
dhs has made it a priority uh i think
that existed
prior to governor abbott uh pressure i'm
not sure what the
format the pressure took but uh we
certainly are happy that he's
happy to hear that we're vaccinating
border patrol agents
totally unrelated question there was a
bill
filed a couple days ago by a bipartisan
group of senators and
congressmen called the journalism
competition and preservation act i'm not
sure if you're familiar with it
it's the one that would give news
organizations a temporary exemption
from antitrust so that they could
collectively bargain
with facebook and google like the
australia
law does the administration have a
position on that
i'll have to check sounds interesting i
want to know the answer um i will check
and see
if we have a position on it
considering that the us has a much
better success rate
in terms of covet vaccinations than the
european union is there an exchange
between the us and brussels and what
kind of advice would you have to the
europeans to do it better
we we absolutely are uh coordinating
discussing
sharing best practices and of course
addressing the global pandemic is
something that comes up
i in nearly every conversation if not
every conversation
the president our secretary of state
national security advisor have
at every level there are a lot of
lessons we've certainly learned
over the last couple of months and i'm
sure our team would be happy to share
them and
you're right we are now vaccinating more
people
on a daily basis than any other country
in the world
thanks everyone you too
you